scott why movies
[Music]
great question
as someone who
lived in a
household that was very
sports oriented growing up
i had a very big disconnect with my
father
because he always wanted me to play
baseball or football
and i was always that quirky kid who
liked to draw and sit down and watch
sesame street
and then i discovered movies
and
movies
were an escape
they made me forget about things that
were going on in my home
they made me
escape into different worlds
they made me feel things they inspired
me
and
i credit
tim burton
for why i do what i do today because
yes i grew up watching pee-wee's
playhouse
but it wasn't until peewee's big
adventure
and then
beetlejuice and batman
that i really
became obsessed
with
movies
and
my world changed entirely
when i saw
tim burns nightmare before christmas
that movie spoke to me
on so many levels
and it made me love the gothic culture
it made me fall in love with stop-motion
animation
but it opened my
mind
in such a way
that i never quite experienced before
i
became so obsessed with this movie
that i bought there was this
art book that came out from it
and
i would take it everywhere and i go go
to the dinner table i had goes for the
the art book
i would
bring it into the bathroom i was just
obsessed with this book
so much so
that it actually made me want to draw
and there was a period of time in my
life where i actually thought i wanted
to become an animator
and i took animation classes
because of this book because of this
movie
and it really just made me fall in love
with
movies animation and the entire thing as
an art form
what's the favorite scene from nightmare
before christmas
[Music]
i mean it's right from the beginning i i
mean
neighbor before christmas has such an
iconic
opening scene with the patrick stewart
voice over
this is halloween i mean all of those
characters coming to life
whether it's lock shock and barrel oogie
boogie
jack skellington sally
all of them coming to life just
i don't know this like warped kid like
just was like inspired almost the same
way like you feel
with tim burton's background right he he
was a weird recluse he was like the
social outcast and he just he drew these
weird characters and these weird
drawings
and
everyone was kind of like what's up with
you growing up and i was not a popular
kid
and watching this movie i felt seen it
was very weird because jack skellington
in a weird way
lives in this world this halloween town
but then he wants something more
and he he wants to become santa claus he
wants to he wants something different he
yearns for change
and i think i resonated with that
not really realizing it as a kid
that
i wasn't like a lot of people my age and
that i always wanted something different
i wanted to be viewed differently
and this movie just spoke to me in a way
that i really can't describe
what other movies have changed your life
well in addition to nightmare before
christmas
there's been a lot of them that
impacted me in different ways throughout
the years
again
i i feel like the ultimate
timber and fanboy here but
between peewee's big adventure
beetlejuice batman batman returns ed
wood
just movies that
just connect me and i again i i
it's about being an outsider struggling
to fit in oh edward scissorhands how can
i forget about edward scissorhands
outsiders trying to fit in in this world
and it's interesting thinking about this
now because as an adult
you reflect upon that
from a childhood perspective of being
the kid who was bullied who was picked
on who never felt like he belonged
and now
being asked this i'm kind of like holy
crap that's the reason why
i connected with these
but as i as i kind of matured
throughout the years
comedies were things that i always
gravitated towards so i have my tim
burton escape for the imagination but i
love comedies
favorite comedies growing up definitely
mike myers anything so i married an axe
murderer
wayne's worlds
austin powers i don't care what anyone
says all three of them
i love gold member i loved fat bastard
i just loved what mike myers did and he
was so
a lot of people say he's very one note
but
i just love that he had again
this imagination of creating these
different characters and it was always a
love of movies right like
austin powers was a love of james bond
and all the characters but it was like
this this parody version of it
and they were so extreme every character
was so silly and over the top whether it
was dr eva with the one million dollars
or you know fat bastard or gold member
going so i like gold you know like i
just really really love that and jim
carrey uh jim carrey is another one
that
talk about someone who i was obsessed
with growing up
ace ventura the mask and dumb and dumber
coming out within a year span
um
man my i don't know how my mom and dad
dealt with me growing up because
i just wanted to go to the movies and
live there my entire life like i just
these these movies these characters
just made me feel so alive and they were
as i as i said earlier they're just an
escape you just you just you wanted to
spend time they felt like friends
and
i love things where i feel something
right whether it's laughter or heart or
a sense of like leaving this world
behind and going into another world
that's really what connected to me and
then when i moved out
here the first time i went to chapman
university
and i did a tour
a couple years prior and i
saw my first indie movies and i i'll
never forget it because it was a
back-to-back it went to
i don't even remember i think it was the
lemlie on sunset five like or now it's
like the amc sunset five but it was like
a lemley theater long time ago
they wouldn't let anyone under the age
of 16 in that theater
and they showed all these great art
house movies
and i remember this so vividly because i
saw lost and delirious which was the
first movie that i have ever watched
that introduced me to lesbian characters
and i remember like seeing this love
story
and i never saw anything like it before
and i fell in love with the with piper
peribo
and
she was so gray in that film and it was
very poetic and i just loved it and then
the following night i went back and i
saw a ghost world
with you know torah birch and scarlett
johansson very very early scarlett
johansson
and it just opened my eyes to
independent cinema because beforehand
like i said earlier i've been watching
all of this mainstream stuff i grew up
mike myers jim carrey tim burton
and i was like these smaller movies
and they were just so incredibly
inspiring and they opened the door to so
many more so that's when i went back and
i started watching things like american
beauty
and i became such an art house champion
and you know inspired me to go to
sundance and and do all these film
festivals because wow there's other
people telling stories that aren't just
hollywood studios
do you remember jim carrion in living
color oh my god fire marshall bill of
course yes yes yes oh
let me show you something yeah yeah
absolutely